[Music]
all right jesus christ man this [ __ ]
here bro
we have never had this much problem
before they're working they're working
on our connections they must be yeah
you guys need a petition a better
service coming to erin yeah no it's
they're expanding [ __ ] around here this
[ __ ] whole
area is growing they're building all
these other houses wow and the service
is getting has together i mean it's 21st
century come on now
not out here this yeah well not out here
it's a you know it's just anything like
[ __ ] ketchup ten years ago there
wasn't even sushi here very frustrating
very frustrating
um so yeah i'm gonna try to get through
this [ __ ] as quickly as possible
um just in case we get [ __ ] cut off
again which i'm sure we will yeah
but uh yeah so i don't know like i
mentioned it earlier i don't know if it
got cut off but
dr kellogg will say
uh developed the first
soy milk which he patented in 1934.
so again very head of his time on that
one
uh he was very into
if you weren't breastfeeding your baby
uh he was very into like feeding your
kid soy milk and it would uh improve
their intestinal fauna which like i said
he was very in uh concerned with
people's
fauna in their intestines which you know
like i said not crazy it is important
but you know a little weird to be that
like worried about it but okay
um so yeah he was into yogurt he did
like soy flour soy bread he did like all
kind of like soy stuff which like i said
taken for granted nowadays pretty weird
back then
now uh
we talked about him doing the
corn flakes and how that was kind of
like a big deal because
it wasn't really i mean
i feel like breakfast wasn't really a
thing in the sense that yeah you ate
when you got up but
there wasn't really like um
a subset of foods that were like
breakfast foods i kind of feel like you
just like ate whatever was left over
from the night before
which was usually just like meat or
whatever
so eating something different for
breakfast was kind of like a big
change
so he was kind of instrumental in that
so let's give him that
but
he also had a lot of patents and other
things having to do with goodness
gracious having to do with uh
various surgical operations various uh
you know kind of medical
stuff
he was actually um
you know he was real big into like
physiotherapy stuff which like i said
nowadays not that weird back then a
little bit strange he was into
electro therapy
hydrotherapy motor therapy
so some of the stuff that he developed
was
stuff that would exercise you if you
couldn't move around all that much you
know what i mean like so it was like a
bed that had like a current running
through it yeah
that would
give you
allegedly
the the same kind of like stimulation as
like taking a four mile walk yeah
okay but y'all believe that when i see
it let me say some [ __ ] about this
i thought you might because you know i'm
into this [ __ ] all right i understand
the old school
workout apparatuses that they use they
were all [ __ ] all of them
they thought that you could do things
like they had these machines that would
sit there and vibrate you you'd put like
a yeah he was into that too yeah
passive exercise that didn't do anything
i mean it was probably better than doing
nothing but no probably not all that
much was the same as doing nothing
uh the only thing they had would have
been like things like stationary
bicycles that does some cardio
they had um
springs that you could pull against
which gave you some muscle strength
nowhere near as good as [ __ ] weights
but in this era they did not even really
have adjustable weight sets
so
the the closest thing they may have had
to that was like some kind of strong
man's barbell which is like a rod with
some cast iron balls spheres on the end
and it was a fixed weight
and all they did was [ __ ]
lifts with it off the ground
they didn't do bench press there's a
bunch of exercises they didn't have
they didn't think like a modern person
because they didn't really understand
how they didn't really understand how
the body worked
they didn't understand how muscles were
built
they didn't they just didn't know
uh
some people were like
the more you worked your body the weaker
you got that you were a battery
you're just you're like wearing your
[ __ ] out yeah which i can understand why
people like it's not true but i can
understand why people would think that
my mom and dad think that oh you'll just
wear yourself out
they don't know what the [ __ ] they're
talking about they don't know how they
don't understand how
metabolism works that you're not a
battery you're a biological system
that responds to input and that [ __ ]
if you work and you eat and you do that
you'll get bigger and stronger
that is not that's how metabolism works
it's like fire
the fire gets bigger if you put more
fuel on it the bigger the fire gets the
more fuel you can put the bigger it gets
this and that that's not how old people
thought and even living people today
don't think i guarantee you donald trump
thinks he's a battery i just look at his
build okay he thinks if he works too
much he'll [ __ ] wear it big fat he's
fat and he's got a little skinny arms
and even though i voted for the
[ __ ] he's funny you know because
he's hilarious he's hilarious he's
hilarious but not but that generation
had [ __ ] a different thinking of the
human body
yeah they're stupid thinking
still has not really they don't know how
metabolism works obviously
even though we've known how that works
for like several decades so like ketchup
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you'll just get tired and wear yourself
out you'll age honestly when i was a kid
yeah my grandparents didn't even think
that yeah they didn't think that
okay [ __ ] have you been
look at those [ __ ] in their 70s
and look at arnold in his 70s
and arnold basically abused himself
with too many [ __ ] uh anabolic
steroids had he toned it down he would
look like that chinese guy that i show
all the time at 72 which he looks like a
young man but they were [ __ ] just
roided the [ __ ] out by the time they
were well that's the thing you can't do
anything to access nothing to excess
right it has to be you just like
whatever you can like you can do
stuff stuff but have fun the right time
and the timing don't do too much of that
stuff and opposed to that stuff just you
can do all the stuff just a little bit
of it a good example for of the old
school would have been jacqueline he
lived at 80 something years old he was
strong till the day he died
and he was never really extreme even
though today he would have done it a
little bit differently but they didn't
really have the knowledge in jack
o'lane's era but jacqueline a bit like
that
um
but these dudes were in another they
were way behind
the the era what we're talking about now
they were still trying to figure out
what was healthy to eat
you know what i mean that's very basic
well the thing you have to think about
like i said dr kellogg here yeah you can
make fun of him all you want and like i
said he did have some like [ __ ] up
views i'm not saying that which i will
get into if we don't get [ __ ] cut off
again
but
he was kind of like ahead of his time
like you don't have to be a vegetarian
but
he was pretty up on
yeah you should have a lot of fiber yeah
you should eat like
more healthy food yeah you should get
some like light you should get some
exercise yeah you should like be
natural don't drink a lot don't drink a
lot of caffeine don't
so
you know not don't do it to excess
because that'd be like [ __ ] [ __ ] like
boring and shitty but
not bad advice yeah and he's gonna say
and here's another thing i want to kind
of convey to you people they didn't know
the standards they didn't know what was
possible like uh i showed earlier on i
showed uh eugene sandow
rebecca [ __ ] freaked out he goes i
jump on that dick you know [ __ ] he he
was a good-looking dude
he was a freak in his time and for many
decades after that people did not
believe that a human being could
actually look like that
what he was doing is he saw ancient
greek sculptures
people in the 1800s 1700s thought that
that was fantasy that people could never
look like that that that was an
idealized cartoonish
sculpture of a man and women eugene goes
no i think people can do that he took
the measurements and worked out until he
got that size and he replicated that to
prove
that that a human could actually do that
but that was 18 something eight late
1800s it took a long time nobody was
really nobody believed that it took
there was no mass media back then it
took a long time for that information
to disseminate throughout the world that
a human could actually do that
the ancient greeks and the [ __ ]
romans knew about physical science but
not
modern people up until very very
recently
so they didn't know what was possible
and this is before sand out they're
trying to figure out what you should eat
that's how basic this is and like i said
so i am willing to uh
as [ __ ] up as like some of dr
kellogg's views were which like i said
i'll get to in a minute
but some of the [ __ ] he came up with
very very ahead of his time yeah very
hit of his time you gotta give him a
call i always do yeah
he did like have some good ideas about
stuff and he was actually like a surgeon
so he did actually have some medical
knowledge more than some people at the
time yeah uh so you know he did as i
said his specialty was more like like
abdominal gynecological type of uh
surgery so he did that kind of stuff you
called to do the quack today but not in
his day he was not in his day i i think
that he was actually uh
a bit ahead of his time uh for the time
sure
um and he
like i said not only foods but he had a
lot of patents as i said not only foods
like corn flakes and stuff like that but
he had a lot of patents on like medical
devices
like he did uh he patented a heated
operating table
okay he had some uh drainage tubes for
like abdominal surgeries so he did like
some he did have some [ __ ] uh patents
for actual medical things that were
kind of big deal at the time
and uh as i said he was kind of into
i said light therapy which sounds a
little weird but
it's not that weird because like i said
there is kind of like seasonal affective
depression which some people do have in
parts of the world where it's dark for a
long time during the winter and if you
don't see a lot of light for a time
people do get depressed about it so he
kind of uh recognized that
and so well let's put that [ __ ]
in a room with like a bunch of
artificial sunlight
and
you know it did seem to help
to some point
uh but then he came up with some weird
[ __ ] like
as i said
passive exercise kind of stuff vibrating
chairs which
i don't know if this is true or not but
some sources that i saw so like the
vibrating chairs that you have which i
think that you can sit in the vibrating
chair in a museum in battle creek
michigan if i'm not mistaken
um
and it might make you poop yourself
involuntarily
true
i don't know i don't think so i'm just
saying it maybe
maybe certain people might poop
themselves that's like the brown
note which yeah that was a good myth
buster's episode
yeah
uh but yeah he so he had the vibrating
chair
uh he had like some stuff like that he
invented like a luffa bit which okay
i'm sorry i can't stay awake go ahead
check out that jay go ahead check it out
if the show's boring go and check out
well i mean it might be very late where
they are
that's what i'm saying
we're having a problem with this show we
keep it keeps dropping off but once once
once it's all done we're gonna we're
gonna piece it together into a single
show well i don't know about the video
one but i'll just piece together the
audio okay all right i'll pull together
all of it well no because what happens
then is that
to piece together the video you have to
download every piece of it and then edit
it back together and then upload it back
again and then you lose all the chat uh
is what happened okay yeah so that's why
that's why i don't usually do that
but i usually do um edit all the audio
together whatever i'll let you do it
thank you i'm gonna let you do it
yeah thanks
uh but yeah so
also i love this i don't know why i
don't know why i love this so much but
he also invented a thing that would like
it was a massager but it would
essentially like slap you
it was like an automatic slapper
you use that the bondage club i guess
put that on the booty
that's what i thought i'm like so it
just like spanx but okay we'll sell that
to our friends
[Laughter]
[ __ ] old little mussolini and his
wife is it like that with that that
thing that was on the howard stern show
the thing that like you said on the
what was that thing called it was
acivian the civilian that's right the
civil you know the civilian vibrated the
[ __ ] out of you and you'd [ __ ] have
an orgasm you had that creepy old dude
what hug you when they said the inventor
of the sibian was always trying to hug
the chicks that were on it well see i
don't want i don't want that dude yeah
yeah he was like you just invented it go
away he did his late 60s and [ __ ] little
[ __ ] crazy so that's the whole reason
he invented that just because so he
could be present he could be president
people sat on him yeah and [ __ ] he'd
sit there and hug him yeah
oh no it's gonna be all right he tried
to make it like a sexual experience that
he was involved in and he was dr sybian
or whatever his name was
just that i'd have been like yeah thanks
for inventing that just get away get
away howard would have him [ __ ] down
and this is back when howard stern was
working for me he would [ __ ] have
that dude down there [ __ ] you know
sweet talking these porn stars
and they were like no no no no the porn
stars didn't want anything to do with
the dude sometimes they would but
i mean this is fine well probably not
funny for the girls because they're
probably like oh god they were gonna
deal with this [ __ ] [ __ ] they're just
they're just it was all it was all the
show it's like look can we just like sit
on the machine and have an orgasm and
not have to deal with this situation
well there were i think there's money
involved and prizes and [ __ ] like that
it was all part of a competition
how much money would you have to give me
to have some like weird ass dude
it would have to be a lot they were porn
stars even if i was a porn star it would
still have to be a lot foreign
i mean it would still have to be a lot a
lot of them but they were on the
standard shirts the stern show so it was
just a show
it's a good idea just like don't involve
yourself in the process however we'll be
talking through the whole thing
laughing at [ __ ] that [ __ ] say it
[ __ ] which to me i feel like that would
like cut into the mood yeah
yeah it did
but it was happening on the radio so
what so yeah he had to say something
he's doing it on the right like not a
video like no one can see this stuff
yeah it's like
well he had a channel too but show up on
e-channel certain clips so you know it
would happen you knew it this is before
the internet was good enough to stream
anything
it was another time it was just it's
still not clearly yeah clearly
[Laughter]
people are saying well you get free
internet uh
it's not free it's not really free well
the hoa is what
it's 100 bucks a month it's 100 bucks a
month and the internet the hoax free
with it and the internet comes with it
and it's actually the highest speed
internet you can get it's better than
what we had earlier like the satellite
internet yeah better than that it's
better than what you can get in this
area for right now but it's everything's
all being built because we're kind of
out in farmland yeah gotta say it's
being built up real quick though as soon
as that freeway is done it's over this
is going to be the suburbs
unless they don't sell those [ __ ]
they better get some good [ __ ] wi-fi
out here i'm going to be very upset they
will they will well another thing is is
uh what 20 uh 10 miles up the road here
there's another [ __ ] town that's
growing pretty big what's the name of
that
dory outdoor
mountain is [ __ ] blowing well mount
dora is like pretty big anyway yeah it's
like a big antiquing place yeah it looks
like old england
antiquing that comes to central florida
goes to mount dora and that's kind of
like florida's weird it's a mixture of
[ __ ] spain and england and the south
and
and indian stuff and bikers
i mean florida's all over the place
that's why that's why nobody considered
us part of the south because
we're kind of the south yeah but
the panhandle is the south the panhandle
the panhandle is mississippi it's the
same central florida is just like who
knows it's a mixture of everything
who knows what you don't know what
you're getting central florida's a lot
more like a higher end and i know
because i've lived there a higher end
version of louisiana or the or or new
orleans it's like that but higher end
nicer
even though i love new orleans lived
there for well i lived on the outskirts
of it for about three or four years and
then was in i was in the baton rouge
area for like eight years so i i like i
like new orleans new orleans is nice too
this is a little higher end
danny rowling says she should put the
curly wig on who
danny rollins
yeah trying to get me to put wigs on you
flirt with me you trying to you trying
to have sex with me
alex joe said that [ __ ] you trying to
have sex with it
no one's trying to have sex with alex
jones i guarantee it that's what made it
so funny
[Laughter]
dude attacked him on the street he's
trying to have sex with me and
everyone's like no
agent hilarious no one's trying to have
sex with you alex jones you are
disgusting
no one's trying to have sex with you
[Laughter]
women always try to take [ __ ] seriously
okay where's this who put this [ __ ] okay
got the willy wonka wig on
the willy wonka wig
[Laughter]
if you want to view
paris
simply look around to view it
come on get that show
well you know all right so
so as i said uh yeah so he was a surgeon
i'm going to put this up here so he did
i guess i have like
like a foe head
he says go on with the show and then
he's like hey look at me then he does
that
no [ __ ] all this [ __ ]
so yeah
his big thing like i said he was a
surgeon so he did like uh he'd take out
people's ovaries so there's that
also he would take out people's like
hemorrhoids why would he take out
ovaries
well if you had like a if you have
ovarian cancer or if you wanted like
yeah there are it's not like he's just
like you know what i think i'm gonna
take your ovaries out so he wasn't like
that no okay there are reasons what like
look you have ovarian cancer or
you don't want to get pregnant like
you're old and you want to get pregnant
or whatever you're having like problems
so we're going to take your ovaries out
all right
there are reasons that you have your
ovaries removed other than just for
shits
arbitrarily just like you know okay
that might happen do you not know much
about girls biology no is there time
about the 1800s i mean they had
[ __ ] that would take a ghost
walls and sew it into another dude's
block that's a whole other dude i mean
yeah but he had we should do a show
about that dude he would [ __ ] cut a
testicle out of a goat
and put that in a dude's [ __ ] nut
sack and sew it up in there and then
they wondered why the dude died
you know what i mean that's well they
thought that it was like sexual uh
prowess it was hrt for for the day they
were we're gonna give you some more
testicles we're gonna give you some more
testosterone also that guy was
instrumental in starting the whole like
[ __ ] uh radio thing
he bought his own radio station oh
really radio to promote yeah um i read
this great book about it yeah the goat
testicle dude
he liked to promote his business
he bought
a couple radio towers
and started his own like radio show
and that was like one of his and he was
like instrumental in starting the whole
like [ __ ]
radio show
thing
yeah
goat testicles yeah
fascinating i love that kind of like
[ __ ] history cheryl's saying that
[ __ ] aj is disgusting you haven't
seen alex jones when he was young he
used to [ __ ] do steroids he was
[ __ ] big he looked great uh but he
was also disgusting no he was no he was
cute when he was he was a good looking
guy when he was in his early 20s he was
real good-looking yeah but his uh the
way that he thought is disgusting how
did you think
uh
you know no how does he think
how does he think that whole weird like
crazy conspiracy theory
disgusting okay
nobody wants to sleep with that come on
had nothing to do with that he was just
on the radio
yeah nobody could see him that was
probably a plus
he's a good looking guy when he was
young he got fat he got fat he got fat
look at that dude and i can't believe
that he's younger than me
now he needs to lose some weight he
knows his grift
i'll say that well whatever jim but i
like his show i think he's [ __ ]
entertaining he knows his grift he's
entertaining
informative very informative sure
if you want to say that very informative
but you know
been pretty accurate
pretty accurate i mean he gets [ __ ]
wrong he gets [ __ ] wrong but he pretty
accurate yeah
fun a lot of fun a lot of fun not so
much a lot of fun i'm not i'm not a big
fan of dudes yelling oh i [ __ ] love
yelling it's testosterone [ __ ]
yeah you're guessing you yell
i gotta make this [ __ ] i yell
to be heard over you
honestly like the [ __ ] that you listen
to i just call it like collectively the
yelling channel
i got that from mystery science theater
the touch of satan the yelling because
they're like oh boy i sure do love the
yelling channel
and i was like oh that's like what you
listen to the yelling channel they're
not yelling they're talking it's just no
they're yelling if you were ever in the
army that's how everybody's [ __ ]
talking everyone's yelling yeah
i don't like noise
people talk too much
they not only talk too much but they
talk too loud wake up you just start
yelling shut the [ __ ] up
god
no one wants to hear you talking
nobody wants to hear you talking
i got my own [ __ ] to do i don't like
listening to people [ __ ] yelling all
right go ahead we're gonna let you know
we're gonna we're gonna lose the focus
straight stop yelling
we're still agreeing though so far i
know i'm just i'm just afraid i'm afraid
we we're almost to the end the stream
god's almost to the end
well are we i see it baby i see the
little market i don't even remember
you're getting there you're getting
there you've made a lot of progress
kind of you getting there
yeah so
right all right so one thing that i want
i think i mentioned this earlier
i will give dr kellogg this is that
he doesn't seem to have like i said i'm
sure he didn't like not cash any checks
but
the profit motive didn't seem to be his
main thing
he did really seem to be like he wanted
to like push his
agenda whatever that was
and so he wasn't really worried all that
much about the money he was more like
worried about like pushing his
health stuff which seemed to be his like
main thing um
again he was really into like light
therapy probably because of like
michigan
dark all the time snowing all the time
[ __ ] like that so we did like light
baths all that kind of stuff we talked
about like vibrational therapy
sounds fun
vibrational chairs which maybe
made people poop themselves allegedly
where do you get this i just it wasn't
me dude somebody some other source said
that the chairs making foods
[Music]
maybe
well not everybody involuntarily
it shook up your it shook up your um
this is why i say
i've been on some [ __ ] wild ass [ __ ]
and [ __ ]
tanks and trucks and [ __ ] jets and
[ __ ]
helicopters flying and that just
vibrating like crazy and nobody ever
[ __ ] took a crap in their [ __ ]
pants we were in the service
and it shouldn't be vibrating are you
crazy yeah no no it doesn't work like
that this is somebody
are you sure this is like a little bit
it's and that was like no it's just like
brown nose [ __ ] because we'd be
vibrating like [ __ ] crazy the whole
thing
for [ __ ] hours flying over the
[ __ ] nap of the earth and [ __ ]
pulling negative g's and
an hour 160 mile an hour wind 200 mile
an hour wind blowing in through the
[ __ ] open doors and [ __ ] and nobody
ever [ __ ] [ __ ] anybody we were just
having fun it's like being on a roller
coaster
that'd be a whole other thing if
everybody was like pooping in their
pants no it's like a roller coaster
you would have loved it jenny you would
have loved it it was like a crosstalk
roller coaster and [ __ ] you saw the
alien 2 when they do the damn [ __ ]
fall and with the um
you know what i mean where the [ __ ]
drop craft comes out of the solaco and
goes through the [ __ ]
into the
[ __ ] planetary atmosphere and they
land it's like that
is it yeah okay uh-60 blackhawks [ __ ]
flying about 200 miles an hour just like
20 feet over the [ __ ] tops of the
trees going through the korean mountains
and [ __ ] korea
going to aviation califax they're like
[ __ ] you look outside and there's
like 30 other aircraft flying along with
you in a big old [ __ ] staggered
ranger type formation it was [ __ ]
great it was like
it's like like a roller coaster
and everybody's carrying guns it's all
camouflaged and [ __ ] [ __ ] camo paint
on your face
the only thing it was missing was
[ __ ] music
there'd be dudes [ __ ] dipping and
trying to spit out the [ __ ] window
and the prop watch blows it back in and
hits you and [ __ ] but it's just you know
what i mean
everybody was all related to each other
anyway
great yeah get spit on you people
laughing
you know
trying to smoke in a [ __ ]
[ __ ] helicopter with the doors open
i've been with you for 10 years i still
don't want your spit on my face
so i told you the time they came and
came and plant his ears dudes are gross
it was [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
dudes are gross what do you do what do
you got man because i got some gum in my
hands
what are you gonna
get your knife to get you mvg's man can
i even like no girl
yeah would ever think of that that is
disgusting hey rash get up that's
disgusting i got some gum in my hands
and the fact okay so what
get your name get your mvg one yeah
that's disgusting two
the fact that you would actually think
that that was worth waking someone up
before yeah it was a commandment and
showing someone else to like
it's a commando this is why women don't
get dudes it's like why why we were out
in a [ __ ] field we've been out there
for a long time you know what i mean we
were in those [ __ ] hooch sure but
poncho hooches and [ __ ]
sure but
belcher
why is that why belcher wanted to
[ __ ] why
do it was belcher's commando mission to
drop come and plot his ears specialists
plot his ears
to make fun of him the day before the
day after
why
you just had to be there to understand
it
as soon as he told me he was doing i was
like okay i got the night vision goggles
to healthy mane
yellow time because it was dark
[Laughter]
so all that [ __ ] fun i'm too old for
this [ __ ] four thousand dollars for this
[ __ ] four thousand dollars in night
vision goggles [ __ ] pvs [ __ ]
sevens were used
so
one specialist could drop come into the
[ __ ] years of another specialist
while he was sleeping in his [ __ ]
sleeping bag in the [ __ ] dead of
night
seems like they're not crazy army [ __ ]
not the best uh
application i can't believe i sources i
can't believe i saw it happen it was one
of the [ __ ] craziest things i've ever
[ __ ] seen in the army and you still
remember it this many years later and
well so i'm not really sure what that
says about you i saw webster beat a
motherfucker's ass with the [ __ ]
rexxact frame while i was drunk that was
another thing that i saw i got it on
video and then he maybe would maybe
[ __ ] delete it afterwards
we got to get back on the show
took that rucksack frame and he was bam
hitting him on the back with it and [ __ ]
dude was all drunk
it was during one of our little drunken
[ __ ] things great yeah
and he didn't even remember it when he
woke up he said didn't you remember
[ __ ] webster was hitting you with the
rucksack frame he was like nah i don't
remember that
[ __ ] website where's that video
camera [ __ ] i said the guy right we
got to erase that i i get article 15 for
that
it's like
he had to erase it he says you don't
remember that his name is taylor do you
remember that taylor no i don't remember
that
it's just [ __ ] funny [ __ ] probably
for the best yeah uh because it was a
giant waste of time yeah everyone he was
so drunk he couldn't walk
you know he's just crawling trying to
crawl around on the ground a webster was
hitting him with a [ __ ] rucksack
frame on his back
big old black good job private first
that was a good that was being a little
white private first class on his back
with a [ __ ] that was the right exact
frame that was a good use it was crazy
man every time i don't understand how i
survived this [ __ ]
dudes were cutting each other's thumbs
off i don't [ __ ] murders had happened
later on i don't understand how i
[ __ ] survived it
some of you guys from 101st know exactly
what i'm talking about
the [ __ ] mass shootings we had
over the damn
dude found his wife [ __ ] working at
the massage parlor outside the [ __ ]
front gate
and he [ __ ] went crazy and [ __ ]
killed her and the other two girls and
all the dudes that were in there that
was [ __ ] 1994.
remember when that [ __ ] happened
yeah i got problems
the last thing i saw happen in the army
i was [ __ ] leaving it was my day to
leave which it was [ __ ] september 24
1994
september 24 94. it was that day it was
my day out
and [ __ ] the day i was leaving i
heard they had that mass shooting that
says that's it [ __ ] eric man get this
[ __ ] we're getting we're out of here
[ __ ] because we were leaving on the
same day
and we [ __ ] got the [ __ ] out of there
before they locked down all the locked
down the entire [ __ ] fort because we
knew that was gonna happen
and it turned out that that was the
turning point at fort campbell fort
campbell kentucky of the 101st airborne
was that [ __ ] mass shooting that was
the day i got out
i didn't know that guy
but uh
yeah it was some weird [ __ ]
cheryl says uh jenny's right that's
disgusting yeah i know i'm right you all
don't understand what happens in some of
these institutions where it's pretty
much all male it was 97 percent men
and women uh we do understand
we do understand it was insane we do
understand and it was disgusting it was
insane it's disgusting i still would
never trade it for anything was the
[ __ ] one of the best well the most
fun times of my life so yeah that's it
you have fun with it you have fun with
that it's just hilarious and your stick
says see the goat testicle helped
seriously yeah go testicles man what's
that dude's name we got to write that
one down
i have
because i read a book about that guy
yeah
and like i said it wasn't just goat
testicles there was a whole thing
about i mean he was an innovator in uh
radio advertising he bought his own
radio station when that wasn't really a
thing
and
it was like a whole thing and so
we should do a show
i mean we should do a show about that
it was uh he did like kind of cut out
goat testicles and put them in human
uh sacks during that time which didn't
always work out so well spoiler alert
but right yeah that was what 18
something 18
yeah it was like late 19th it was like
late 19th century okay so 1880s 18
around that time 1890s they had isolated
the hormone testosterone
and they knew that it was protective i
knew where their head was at
but
they had isolated the hormone
testosterone they knew what that did
they knew that it came from the testes
they knew that it produced masculinity
or masculine
traits they knew that an older minute
declined
and giving them
that information in the 1800s was very
[ __ ] dangerous because they were
trying to [ __ ]
increase the testosterone in men before
they could produce testosterone
synthetically so they were trying to
take [ __ ]
well goats [ __ ] a lot right yeah that's
what the urban legend says so they take
it so let's take testicles out of goats
and put that in a man and put them in a
human sack and see how that works out
they didn't connect it they just
and i'm pretty sure that dude was not
like an actual doctor now they had some
things you know i mean you could take a
bunch of rat nuts and dog nuts and cat
nuts that were taken off cut off of
animals
from the [ __ ] slaughterhouses
and bull nuts you could take that
anything taken off of an animal in the
slaughterhouses or
[ __ ] at the veterinarian when they're
fixing animals they were taking that and
putting that in the centrifuge and
trying to get the [ __ ] testosterone
out of it and they were injecting that
into dudes too but it didn't work
because
the esterism
isn't correct it it falls apart too
quickly they didn't have the chemistry
right you have to fix it
with a bunch of other with a couple
other little molecules to get it right
so you could have it to where it would
just
where its half-life wasn't so short
but that took them a long time to figure
that out
then that's where hrt and steroids well
as i said yeah um
everything like i can't [ __ ] on people
too much
uh from the old days they were just
going on the information they had which
was not they didn't have the idea they
didn't have the tools and i mean you
know 200 years from now what will people
be like [ __ ] on us about i'm sure
there will be something because we don't
know everything either
but yeah
um
they kind of went at [ __ ] like uh half
cocked back then yeah gotta say
and you know well they had an idea it's
like well
if
goats [ __ ] a lot then we should just
like cut some nuts out of goats and put
them in a person and that should work
out just fine
eventually they were able to [ __ ]
synthesize the testosterone type
molecules that could last long enough to
where you could inject them in somebody
and then they took that and they said
well we can approve them and they made
improved versions of that and that's
where state tests that's where steroids
came from they're just improved versions
of testosterone
they just work better
and uh
that's out there too but that those
didn't appear until 50s 1960s yeah much
later much later i mean much later than
what i was talking about because
honestly
like i said i [ __ ] on dr kellogg he did
have some crazy ideas which like i said
i do want to get into the eugenics
so let's not get too excited
um well i get some other [ __ ] to go into
uh you know but he did come with some
good [ __ ] he had some like foot
massagers okay fine
um
[Music]
he had a
what wikipedia calls a mechanical
slapping
massage device
i'm not really sure what that
is
it's just some device that slaps you
which okay some people are probably into
that uh they had a kneading apparatus
which i have a free one of those it's
called a cat
um so i don't know costs about 30
40 300 in today's money so you know
again i have a free one
uh so let's see uh also 1936 he patented
his uh
his uh you know anime thing
he had a machine that would
give enemas more uh quickly and
efficiently not necessarily yogurt
but it could be anything it could be any
liquid that you wanted to shoot up your
butt it's not judging it's a fast and
efficient animal it's a passion it's a
fast and efficient
he was really into like a clean colon
god damn it this dude had he was anally
fixated i yeah freud would have a field
day yeah with this stuff i'm just saying
uh also as i said
uh dr kellogg really into the
anti-tobacco thing
and he got all on board with that like
all the time
i smoked i mean yeah i did too yeah not
good honestly if other people want to
smoke i'm not bothered um bad for you it
is bad for you
but a lot of things are bad for you i'm
not all that bothered about like
yeah people can smoke around me i don't
really care um it doesn't bother me but
if it does bother you then that doesn't
bother me either i'm really not
judgmental about it
i'm just it doesn't affect me in any way
i'm not bothered by it one way or the
other
um but also
very very anti-alcohol
[Music]
again
i like alcohol obviously but
again if some people don't like it
because look i know some people that
we're alcoholics and they're now sober
and
they like to go out and see their
friends and stuff but they don't want to
drink
and
i'm not going to give them [ __ ] about it
no one's going to give them [ __ ] about
it so
i'm not i'm not bothered but
he was very very anti-alcohol again i'm
not bothered by that but
also
very anti-caffeine no coffee no tea
no nothing
again i don't know man that's kind of
like
[ __ ] that's a little too much
um so yeah so he had a whole thing about
[ __ ] he also had a weird thing about
he had a weird thing about water
being
essentially like a cure-all i kind of
feel like he
wrote some [ __ ] about water being like
water is kind of like oh it's you know
you can give it to like kill pain and
you can give it to like
it has a
because of its vital properties it has
all these um you know things that it's
like the best medicine
so even though he was
medically trained
and wasn't averse as far as i am aware
of like giving people medicine when they
actually needed it i kind of feel like
he was one of those [ __ ] that
was like well if he just has like some
random ass
you know
malady or whatever he's just gonna give
you water for this stuff because that
would probably cure it
he had that kind of like like just take
water for everything so he it was a
hydrotherapy
he uh spent a lot of time on that
now
uh what else was i gonna talk about so
we talked about
the sexually transmitted diseases like
syphilis and stuff
and masturbation we talked about that
and uh
yes the whole graham cracker thing
yeah graham crackers in case you guys
didn't know
uh dr kellogg didn't invent those but
ellen white
who was the
seventh-day adventist like mentor of dr
kellogg
she kind of came up with those
the whole point of corn flakes and
uh you know graham crackers
was that
we are giving you food that is not all
that exciting
and
that's the reason for that food existing
you eat that food
it's just to
sustain you
calorically but you can't get too
excited about it or too like
emotional about it
with sugar or spice or anything like
that because then you might want to hump
something or touch yourself or whatever
and that's like not allowed
so
there was that whole thing
now let's kind of talk about i think i
talked about this before but
as i said uh
dr kellogg and i think other seventh-day
adventists as well
they thought if you're super into like
spicy foods or
sugary foods or whatever um
round shoulders and boldness
uh signs of a chronic masturbator
masturbator
and uh you know you did that they cut
your [ __ ] off so you know
great
um and i think we mentioned this earlier
but in case you were not here uh zach
asked us
if
dr kellogg had been the one to
popularize
the widespread american thing of like
circumcising male babies
that is a very common
misconception
it was not actually dr kellogg
that did that
he was into circumcising boys
but
and girls great
so um but he was more into that to stop
people from masturbating he was also
into like strapping people to beds and
doing various uh putting people in cages
and their genitals and cages and stuff
to keep them from like masturbating um
he wasn't as far as i'm aware
an advocate of just circumcising people
uh in aggregate he was just kind of like
we're doing that just to keep people
from like uh excessive masturbating
which i guess he thought was a problem
um so you know
again he thought that masturbating was
not only just masturbating but also uh
it was like a moral
failing like it was a
public vice it would make you
morally degenerate in other ways so he
wanted to prevent it
and he tried to prevent it from a very
young age so he would do things like
take little boys and little girls and he
would like strap them to beds
um
you know he would do things like he
would do like clitoridectomies
things like that so you know [ __ ] up
kind of
now let's talk a little bit about
eugenics because
during this time period
it was not unusual for people that have
these kind of views on hygiene
in general
to be
eugenicists
so dr kellogg no different
he was very into um
oddly even though he claimed i don't
know if this is true or not he that he
was married his wife for 40 years and
they never had sex or only had sex very
infrequently
they fostered
a lot of kids
some of whom
were not white
but
uh dr kellogg there
not really a big fan of the non-white
races he thought they were quote unquote
degenerate
and not a big fan of them
reproducing
uh so he was all in on that
let's uh you know deem who is worthy to
reproduce
situation
so 1906
him
and this other dude named irving fisher
and yet another dude named charles
davenport
they started this thing called the race
betterment
foundation
1906.
and uh
so
again kellogg vary in favor of racial
segregation
uh not a big fan of immigration
and he thought that like non-whites were
polluting the gene pools that was that
uh
again didn't really like racial mixing
and he thought that there should be a
thing
that every that like the race betterment
foundation should keep track
of everyone's
pedigree
so they could hook up people that were
racially pure
to
mix with one another
sounds a little
dubious does it not yes
there was that
uh also he was big into force
sterilization
of people who he deemed
not
not sufficient to reproduce so you know
that was kind of a big thing back then
uh also the
little uh kind of
race betterment foundation that they did
they had better baby contests god it
sounds so naughty seem naughty
uh yeah they had better baby contests
who could have the but well i know it
was who can have the best big fat white
white baby yeah let's stop it
no that's what they were doing that's
what they were doing all right she's
mischaracterizing what the [ __ ] i'm not
that's what they were doing yeah but you
have to look at it in the [ __ ]
entirety of the context
yeah i know the context that's what they
were doing
these are farming
people basically yes i know they have
been raising pigs and cows and [ __ ]
chickens and showing them who has the
best pigs and cows they just naturally
did the same thing with their children
who has the best daughters
i understand
where the thinking came from that
doesn't mean it's good though i think it
is i think it kind of is it's just
bettering bettering your yourself and
your people and your children and
i i don't think there's anything wrong
with it of course not you know what i
mean just trying to
marry the best woman well nature does
that
you're marrying the best
partner you can marry to have children
that's just the natural
that's just the natural thing that
happens all right and what that equates
to in the country in the country context
is motherfucker's gonna have a beauty
contest that's
it's the same thing as a beauty contest
that's all it is and then let's go back
to like the [ __ ] jonbenet ramsay
thing where like we're dressing
babies up as
that's not the country that's not the
country though like you talked about
well nowadays it is yeah that's not the
country nowadays [ __ ] jonbenet ramsey
and all that [ __ ] i think it was
happening out in l.a that was a little
bit wasn't that california i think it
was and that that wasn't poor country
people i think it was rich people no i'm
just saying but that whole like [ __ ]
mindset is that's a whole yeah that's
the whole thing but that was a little
bit different that was i think mothers
trying to live vicariously
through
daughters who were kind of like their
personal dolls like he dressed up like a
dog
that's so creepy that was like they were
trying to make a mini me we know women
like that yeah they're trying to make a
mini me still creepy
uh that's not what beauty contests were
and that's not what the eugenics
movement was it was more like [ __ ]
uh [ __ ] having more to do with damn
cattle ranching more than anything else
well
i get that you know but it's still
creepy it's still great it's been going
on for thousands of years it's still
creepy been going on forever
so creepy sorry
i don't think it's creepy yeah it's
happening whether you want it or not
because if
everybody everybody marries the person
that they the best person they can get
and have kids they're proud of the kids
and then they show the kids off and then
well i'm not marrying a six-year-old boy
am i
no
i that that's totally out from left
field i don't have it's not that has
nothing to do with what i was talking
about yeah
no not at all
that has nothing to do with what i was
talking about
yeah okay nothing it was just
people
were showing off their best-looking sons
and their best-looking daughters
but in the in in in in the beauty
contest thing you're talking about
people that were eligible for marriage
that was the the country
they weren't little kids they were
teenagers who were ready to accept
nowadays
jonbenet ramsay was like six that wasn't
nowadays that was the 80s wasn't it her
90s no that was not that long ago when
was that
that was 90s or 2000s yeah that's a long
time ago it's not a long time 25 years
it's not a long time and it's not the
quite the same thing of what this was
that was more this is more of an
agricultural thing more marriage related
you know what i mean you're trying to
make it seem like you're really trying
to like [ __ ] explain away this stuff
it was it's not being creepy i don't
think well but it is creepy traditional
creepy they're trying to marry off
daughters and traditional [ __ ] can be
creepy okay sorry
it just can
i know you're very into this traditional
thing but it's very creepy
that's creepy
that's a little
kid
so no no they were teenagers stop it
jonbenet ramsay was not a teenager but
that's not what we're talking about here
we're talking about but i brought that
up and then you were trying to like
explain it away we're talking about the
eugenics movements and beauty contests
which is more kind of like those were
babies no they were babies no they were
not yes they were better
baby contests they had babies
oh well there were i'm not trying to
marry those though
but they're talking about that's babies
yeah that's still that's more creepy
that's more to do with the parents
though that's creepy that's more to do
well yeah the parents are still to blame
what i was talking about but it's
equally creepy what i was talking about
creepy mostly still creepy what i was
talking about is the beauty pageants and
that was
you know what i mean teenagers
late teens people getting ready to get
married that was mostly what it was
but that is not what i'm talking about
i'm talking about
babies they were doing a baby
they're they're [ __ ] contests they're
competing on who has the cutest pookie
that's all pookie's a cat
yeah but they were doing it with their
children too
yeah still creepy it's creepy if you're
sexualizing it which a lot of this stuff
is and i kind of feel like back in the
old days
they didn't acknowledge that it was
sexual even though it clearly was they
weren't really talking about it though
nowadays we see that [ __ ] for what it
was thankfully but back then they didn't
really want to admit it
well to me now that's just sexy so i
don't really care about it that was
between women well that's you that was
women doing that [ __ ] if you're not a
pedo yeah then you don't see it like
that but a lot of dudes are pedos and
they do see it like that bet you there
were no dudes involved in that [ __ ] it
was all women looking at who had the
cutest i do not believe that
for one second all right not for one
second
um
you know like i said
i have to see the source material
i know where that shit's coming i have
to see the source
i don't know exactly what you're talking
about because i haven't seen it
i mean it's
one it's very weird to be talking about
humans like you talk about
your livestock
that's a little problematic i don't
think so it's about the same
okay cool especially but the people of
that time didn't see a big difference
i still don't really see a big
difference people are only temporary
they're born they live they die they
just
if you were to actually stand back from
it and look at it we're kind of like
teetsy flies
you're born you live you die certain
generations happen
it happens quickly from the grand scheme
of things
it's just you can't really over
you can't really
i don't really over emphasize the
importance of life
because i don't really think there's
much meaning to it you're born you live
you die you die you're forgotten what is
the meaning of life what is the meaning
of life of a cat
nobody knows it's just it's just are you
having an existential crisis right here
on the show no not at all no no
you sound like you are no i'm just
saying there isn't much of a meaning to
any of this we're just here so i could
just drop dead right now and you would
not care
they didn't say that now you're infer
another thing i'm saying there isn't
much meaning to it
well that's interesting
in what you're saying
that's implicit in what you're saying
there isn't really a great meaning into
meaning to it it's just so i could kill
you right now and it wouldn't matter no
it wouldn't matter because the [ __ ]
law would come and get you
i'm just saying that
okay
what is the meaning of a cat
of the life of a cat what is its meaning
well what i'm trying to say what is the
meaning of a [ __ ] horseshoe crab what
is the meaning of its life
i can't i can't your problem
your problem is
tom
that you are trying to assign meaning
from some kind of upper echelon yeah and
the upper echelon does not exist well
that's in your opinion
so
meaning
comes from what you assign to it
which to me is more meaningful okay
um
because i do not believe in any kind of
like upper echelon there is no god there
is no
higher anything
so the meaning that you find in life is
meaning that you make for yourself
in which case
it does not matter
that
oh well
it's just a cat or it's just a person
they'll die it doesn't matter
um it matters to you and they're so
you're making the meaning right well to
me
uh makes life more meaningful because
then you're like well yeah i mean if if
you're going from your point of view
then nothing matters i could die right
now and you would not give a [ __ ]
because no you don't i didn't say
because i don't matter i'm just another
person i'm just like a crab or i said
no you're you're reading and you're
you're no that's implicit in what you're
saying that's implicit in what you're
saying all right no that's not what i'm
saying you fee you need um some kind of
like upper authority to give meaning to
life there is no such thing there is no
such thing no i don't you have to assign
your own meaning to things i don't think
there is a meaning to it i don't know
which i don't think but you should
assign your own meaning because you
assign them because you assign your own
meaning to your life and then you die
then you were the only one that cared
about it so your meaning of yourself oh
no so whoever cares about you whoever
cared about you also yeah but they died
assigned me but they died okay and then
when they vanished
that's okay
that's what i'm saying that's what i'm
saying no what is the meaning because
look you have
billions of people in the past are dead
and the people that knew them are dead
but we mostly forget sure but well not
necessarily because honestly look at
what their lives mean
okay but morrissey asked that
when he's going through the [ __ ]
cemetery gates yeah but what did they do
what did they like yes but people like
that
um see
people like that no what i'm gonna say
is that people like that
they're well they're thinking too much
about it one
um you shouldn't like project too far
into the future because obviously like
everyone
a hundred years from now 200 years from
now most people will be forgotten okay
but that's fine it's fine yeah um i'm
not bothered by that
and
honestly i'm kind of like content with
if people who are alive at the same time
as me
um who loved me and when i was gone they
remembered me for a few years after i
was gone that's fine
that's fine that's enough for me
wins every beauty contest she does okay
there you go all right she knows
everything no but what i'm saying is
that
honestly if you were famous
like [ __ ] we were just watching the
black cat from the 30s yeah last night
uh with boris karloff and billa lugosi
who are both dead but
we still
appreciate them yeah even though they're
dead because i was like man they were
[ __ ] awesome in that movie that was
an awesome movie
so
we still remember them even after
they're dead and honestly that's really
all you can ask for and i'm not really
asking for more than that and i don't
think that anyone should okay to be
honest um it doesn't bother me that
200 years from now no one will remember
who i am that's fine okay fine i i'm not
bothered by it i'll be dead i won't care
i can't believe that we got through this
look at that
well yeah it's almost over okay uh so
honestly like i don't really know
to be honest i think it's better
to be able to assign your own meaning to
things yeah
i don't think that you need to wait for
some
mythological
greater being to give your life meaning
i think you have meaning implicitly
where are you getting this who
who's saying this me okay i'm not nobody
i'm not saying about mythological beings
i'm saying that
uh when you look at the big picture i
don't really think there's much meaning
to it to any of it
we just think there is because we're us
but i don't know if there's much meaning
to it
it's just well why don't you just dive
in
well no and no one will care no
just because they're what you you see
here's the thing you think it has to
have meaning
i don't think it does i did not say that
okay i don't think it has to have
meaning i'm still having fun but the but
the fun doesn't have anything having to
do with meaning
honestly i don't think you're listening
to anything that i said okay fine you're
drunk
[Laughter]
you're not listening to anything that i
said i listened to you sam just no you
didn't understand it okay hold on
hold on you did it
go ahead go ahead and finish the case
what's up
holy [ __ ]
why does this have to be this hard i
don't understand
yeah uh pookie does win every beauty
contest honestly she's the cutest spooky
ever and she knows that because i tell
her every day
so she's like the cutest ever so yeah
what were you talking about eugenics
so
okay so this is what i'm talking about
dudes that have some good ideas this
dude had some good ideas he was all at
health food
yeah you should get some light you
should get them exercise eat some fiber
eat some vegetables don't eat so much
meat
cool
don't drink so much alcohol don't drink
so much caffeine fine
but
then he kind of
took a hard right into like [ __ ]
don't masturbate again
okay not so much and then
let's not let any of the quote unquote
inferior races let's not let them like
reproduce he was a big fan of
sterilizing
people that you know were deemed
unworthy at least from his point of view
and his
brethren if you want to call it that
uh the weird thing about it though is
that as i said
i don't know if him and his wife
actually never had sex
i don't know if i entirely buy that i
don't think i entirely buy that but they
didn't have any kids of their own but
they did foster
a [ __ ] ton of kids i think it was like
40 something kids that they fostered
some of him were black
but
he still had that point of view
that they were quote unquote inferior
and that they should not
reproduce so he even like started
a whole
like conference about the stuff like
no one should racial mix okay so they
did like this whole race betterment
conference like i said they had a better
baby contest like who's got the best
white ass baby
let's like have a contest about it
oh my god this stuff is so gross so yeah
um the weird thing about it though was
that even though he was into
that kind of stuff
in his
uh you know
in the battle creek sanitarium
it was mostly white not gonna lie but
he was kind of against segregation
somewhat in
his you know in the clientele at least
so at least if you're black and kind of
famous like sojourner truth
um he would let you in there
so there was that so he wasn't like
entirely
that but
i don't know it's so complicated he's
like such a complicated character
in matter of fact this is something that
i found on one website
sojourn truth
uh stayed at the sanitarium
apparently and
legend has it
that he grafted some of his own skin
onto her leg
when she had an ulcer i don't know if
that's true or not
but that's the legend going around so he
couldn't have been that
weirded out about like race
but still
kind of [ __ ] up just saying
now
very famously
dr john kellogg and his brother will who
as i said sued him about the whole
kellogg name will got the name he made
the cornflakes john made other things
but he had to call them something else
so there was like a rift there
so
uh so there was a whole like conflict
their whole entire lives
now on his deathbed allegedly
dr john kellogg wrote a letter to his
brother will apologizing
maybe
for being a douche to him seven pages
long
part of which said i earnestly desire to
make amends for any wrong or injustice
of any sort i have done to you which
sounds like an apology
but
okay fine i'm willing to give him like
the benefit of doubt whatever you think
i did bad i'm sorry for that [ __ ]
again sounds like an apology but okay
better than nothing
so he writes it on his deathbed
but
his secretary
i don't know why what's up pope she came
before she's like [ __ ] she's like
[ __ ] this [ __ ] i don't want to be on
the show she's like i don't want to be
on a journey his secretary
um i don't know why
didn't want to deliver it to will
so william
never got it
so he had written a seven page long
letter apologizing allegedly for
yeah i was a dick and it's like you know
why didn't we ever make amends this
whole time we were like feuding
our whole entire now i'm dying blah blah
blah so he writes him a letter
secretary doesn't deliver it because
she's like [ __ ] that [ __ ] i don't know
why so
he didn't deliver it
uh so
william didn't find out
that his older brother had like
apologized until the [ __ ] was already
dead then he's like well a little late
now
that
we'll say though
and we talked about this earlier dr
kellogg
maybe he was on to something with this
health [ __ ] because he did live until he
was 91 now he did say that he was going
to live till he was 100
but he didn't but 91 is still pretty
good ginny you got to see the dark side
did it be 91 790 no he said he was going
to i'm gonna live till i'm 100 years old
then i was like oh nine years short nine
years in those days what year was that
he died you know 1943. [ __ ]
pretty good he went almost to the
[ __ ] end of world war ii pretty good
i'm not [ __ ] on him he almost pretty
good he almost saw that
bomb
91 pretty old for 1943. pretty old he
probably had no idea what's going on
leave him germans alone
i kind of feel like he was probably yeah
yeah
shut up hitler's cool yeah what's up
with the atomic bomb yeah drop this drop
what time there's no such thing as
what's that cloud i'm yelling at it yeah
yeah
yeah
i mean
okay
i'm not [ __ ] on him too much he did
have like some good ideas
but
like any person he was a product of his
time
okay
let's say that
uh he had some good ideas he was very
ahead of his time in some ways like i
said he came with like [ __ ] meat
substitutes [ __ ] nut butters oh like
all kind of stuff
that we nowadays like take for granted
soy milk yeah
nobody blinks an eye at that nowadays
back then that was weird don't drink
that [ __ ]
would i drank it
almond milk's a lot better for you well
almond milk well almond milk honestly
tastes a lot better
soy milk is okay but it tastes a little
weird
i think some people say that it produ it
[ __ ] acts a little bit too much it's
not real good for men because it [ __ ]
it carries estrogens and estrogen-like
compounds alex john says that no no no
it's not just
[ __ ] a lot of guys say that they've
done a lot of tests on that his estrogen
likes that it turns frogs into like
[ __ ] no that's an interesting drag
queen
whatever the [ __ ] that's true though
that's true what are you talking about
no no that's true atrazine they're
talking about the uh stuff in roundup
the runoff from roundup
[ __ ] it doesn't cause the frogs to be
gay he was joking around it causes them
to be intersex
which that's some weird [ __ ]
[ __ ] which that's it's just a genetic
mutation
not really intersex more like
hermaphrodites
and they do weird [ __ ] like the males
try to have sex with each other instead
of the females so so but it's because
there's some chemical confusions going
on because it acts like a hormone
animals don't respond the same way to
hormones as conscious more higher
animals do you know i mean like i [ __ ]
with hormones all the time they do [ __ ]
with you hormones are hell of a drug
but uh are they yeah but [ __ ] certain
hormones
atrazine will get in there and it'll act
like a hormone it's like a hormone minor
mimicker and it'll [ __ ] up them damn
frogs
and they're [ __ ] up their mating
process and then they're uh some of them
are born they're kind of hermaphroditic
looking that's what he's talking about
he was just checking around though that
happens with humans though just like
naturally
so
yeah there's also mutations that can
cause that well sure i know i'm just
saying that doesn't have anything to do
with that we're talking about roundup
that's what he's talking about atrazine
gilded age phoenix says in the country
you show off your daughters at the state
fair just like zuckerman's famous pigs
yeah men's famous yeah i don't
understand a problem some pig they're
trying to
marry off him daughters back it was back
in the day
back in the day that was charlotte's web
did you read that yeah you didn't read
charlotte's website a long time when i
was a kid
it's not big but uh tom's explaining the
world they did that [ __ ] yeah yeah they
did that [ __ ] they still do that [ __ ]
it's kind of like something out of the
middle east or something you know i mean
marrying off daughters and doll reasons
uh they're talking about almond milk
yeah i'm honestly i was into well okay
what happened with me was that i was uh
really when i was a kid
i was really into drinking like whole
milk but
you know
my
body type that just like makes me bloat
out so i had to like
i went to skim milk which is fine but
then like i went to soy milk which is
fine but like tastes a little weird
but when they introduced like other
nut milks like almond milk like cashew
milk all that kind of stuff
man that shit's like so much better it's
so much better soy milk tastes a little
strange
i do like that they offer it like at
starbucks and stuff but it is like kind
of weird i think they have almond milk
it [ __ ] that [ __ ] now too becca says
she likes that nut milk
yeah rebecca out there chasing that nut
milk
dumping groceries
[Laughter]
you're gross yeah nut milk
see that was one of the that was one of
the when i was doing the uh notes i was
kind of like man when i say nut milk
we're gonna go off on a whole thing
there's gonna be like three hours that
i'm gonna lose because you're like
talking about nut milk
and then breakfast it chases meat
the nut milk is chasing rebecca
damn
um i do like almond milk actually yeah
almond milk is pretty good it's just not
quite as honestly i don't think we buy
actual milk anymore no i don't buy
something we just buy almond milk mostly
but
almond milk um dried milk uh i like i'll
use i'll buy neato for for certain
recipes
because it's good to have some powdered
milk around yeah we do have powdered
milk but we do for quite a coffee powder
for cold milk we do have like almond
milk usually like in the cartons
i just we just drink it because it's
it's lower in calorie
it's a lot more it's a lot better in
terms of calories and here's the thing
and she was talking about
milk and soy milk earlier on
and you guys know me i'm i'm not
some [ __ ] granola crunchy
[ __ ]
i like milk because i grew up drinking
things like cereal and drinking
chocolate milk and there's just
something cultural with westerners about
drinking milk it is a good drink it's
nice and [ __ ] thick and it's creamy
and you can do a bunch of [ __ ] with it
um it's not that good for you it's got
[ __ ] lactic acids in it which are not
that great for you they're good for
little children and baby cows and [ __ ]
but they're not real good for adults and
it's got a lot of calories in it so if
you're watching your weight or watching
calories
milk is not really a good way to go it's
you have to have it for recipes
certain recipes especially anything it's
kind of french based is going to have a
bunch of milk in it
so you have to have it around but when
it comes to like you're going to get a
bowl of cereal
you're better off [ __ ] using almond
milk than that
and if you like the cocoa krispies you
might as well just get some chocolate
almond milk and put some regular rice
krispies in it it's a real similar
experience and a lot better calories and
protein wise and lower in fat and it's
just
arnold drinks it but he drinks milk too
his [ __ ] lies says he's vegan
he's not vegan
to be honest i've never really noticed
all i mean it's been years and years
because like i said when i was growing
up i was really into the whole milk but
i think that mostly like
made me fat
so i switched on you well i switched to
skim milk
and then later i went to soy milk and
then when almond milk came out i was
like thank god
something that tastes better than that
so i went to that and that actually is
much better
so
honestly um
we don't really drink i don't think i've
drank whole milk for a while
god many many years
it's good for some things other things
just on a daily basis you don't want to
drink that
not too much of it it's not that good
for you
i mean depending on where your genetics
come from it's like really hard for some
people to digest some people could
probably tolerate it better than others
just like anything else now it kind of
sucks because there's a whole milk
industry and recently they were pouring
a bunch of milk out because the [ __ ]
transportation problems which there went
on a bunch of [ __ ] dairy milk you
know i saw that [ __ ] on video
you know that could offend somebody
but really
when you really look at it from the
point of view of [ __ ]
milk is best used in [ __ ] things like
ice cream
all right
put sugar in it and flavoring and
[ __ ] cool it and make some like
[ __ ] low-fat ice cream with it with
milk
[ __ ] high-fat ice cream or real ice
cream's cream
and milk
but [ __ ] you can make a lot of
[ __ ] ice cream with it i'd rather
have ice cream than milk actually
yeah it's it's good for you but give
everybody treats you know what i mean i
mean if you're gonna have i'm kind of
like look if you're gonna have the
calories you can make an ice cream you
might have had you might as well have
something like really good yeah you know
what i mean
make ice cream out of it or make a bunch
of [ __ ] chocolate out of it or makes
make some cream make some [ __ ]
cheesecake out of it like i said i gotta
watch like every calorie so
if i'm gonna have something like
really high calorie it better be
something really really [ __ ] good
yeah really good
i don't want to waste calories on like
some [ __ ] although we have to ask
myself i have to ask myself this
can almond milk be supplied to everybody
is it easier to supply in the united
states is it easier to supply people
with [ __ ] um
cow milk or almond milk i don't know
well
it might be actually easier to supply
well nowadays it might be probably but i
don't know like i don't know what the um
[Music]
i i don't really know what like what the
what the growth pattern is like for
almonds and stuff so i don't really know
like how widespread that is
like because i know in the us like you
know cows are very are ubiquitous
yeah we got [ __ ] 200 of them right
over there a couple but like i said
dairy cows versus meat cows
yeah that's like two different things so
i'm not really sure
how how that shakes like i said to go
back to the beginning of the show
variety is really where humans need to
be they should have a little bit of
everything so i don't believe in all
this don't eat this at all no no eat a
little bit of everything don't ever do
that
um i kind of feel like you're just
shooting yourself in the balls doing
that because it's like if you tell
yourself don't ever eat this ever
then that's gonna make you want it more
we got friends like sophie she's
probably listening to the show later she
listens to recorded she's [ __ ]
hardcore vegan she doesn't even eat
anything out of an animal i just think
it's a bad idea there's a lot of but you
can do that if you want you could get
that on it i can understand where you
could be like mostly vegetarian with a
bunch of pescatarian stuff
but then you eat whey protein she won't
even eat whey protein because that's
[ __ ] microbes i i don't understand
that you know what i mean
microbes are not animals in the way that
she's thinking they are
eat whey protein and then there's all
kinds of other [ __ ] you know there's
milks and cheeses and [ __ ] eat to eat it
it's there if not then that animal is is
making a sacrifice in vain i mean
someone else will buy it someone else
will just buy it but well like i said
it's that's going back to what i said
earlier it's like look people can eat
whatever they want it doesn't affect me
really
um
you eat what you want to eat i'm not
going to like get all up in your [ __ ]
about it i say
eat that's your business eat a little
bit of everything eat what's available
to you and eat within moderation and
it'll be fine
you we evolved to be eating a variety of
stuff but like i said that's why i don't
get all up on people's uh case about you
want to be a vegetarian you want to be a
vegan you want to like be a pesky
whatever the [ __ ] you want to do
it really doesn't affect me all that
much
you eat what you want to eat if you i
will say this
as a person has studied this intensively
looked at all the [ __ ] evidence and
[ __ ] listen to all the dudes that did
all the [ __ ] and tom knows everything
tom knows everything extreme in the
extreme cases
one of the finest diets known to man is
pescetarianism if you could afford to
eat seafood and fish and vegetables
that's all you need right there very
high quality protein well i mean i'm a
big fan of seafood pescatarianism
i like other meats too but yeah honestly
there's a quality of product all things
being equal if somebody told me you
couldn't eat any meat
other than pro than uh seafood
i would
i wouldn't be all that mad about it
it's very i do like other meats but
i could live on just like seafood it has
very good fats the type of fats that it
has are good for you it's very low in
the bad kind of fats it's very low in
calories
but very high in protein so the ratios
are real good there with all that
seafood
and then put vegetables on top of that
you can build a lot of lean muscle mass
and still remain healthy
um
pescetarianism with is very good diet
very good
um
but you know i i like my pork and
chicken and beef though too i'll throw
that in there the only problem with
pescetarianism is that that's an
expensive diet in the united states
honestly japan it would be a lot easier
if i could eat just on seafood and maybe
the occasional or rare steak that'd be
good yeah
i could do that yeah
i don't need chicken or pork or any of
that your average japanese is kind of
pescetarian basically so their builds
are i love fish i love seafood i love
all that stuff but every now and then i
want a big ass [ __ ] rare yeah the
exception is the japanese eat a lot of
rice and caucasians and africans don't
don't have most of us most caucasians
and most africans
do not have the genetics that you need
to um process rice properly without
gaining a whole bunch of weight
i mean uh white people are black people
gain a lot more weight off rice than a
than a japanese or an asian person would
they've been eating that for thousands
of years
and
white people and black people would tend
towards getting a lot of weight and
gaining weight on that
and having uh what do you call it uh
diabetes it's it's it's it's it's a
sugar it's carbohydrates
captain blair says jen ever try and like
carnation instant breakfast i have
but
not a fan if you look at the [ __ ]
details of carnation instant breakfast
you might as well drink chocolate milk
honestly if i'm gonna have breakfast
which i usually don't yeah um
for breakfast i usually have a cup of
coffee and that's it
if i'm gonna eat breakfast i will have
a hard-boiled egg or maybe two
but
or maybe a packet of oatmeal
but normally i do not eat breakfast i
don't usually eat i like breakfast i'm
not saying that but it's like he doesn't
usually like roll out of bed until 10
10 or 11 until like lunch time yeah and
i usually get up at like 6.
so i get up two just i fall back asleep
i know yeah
i woke up this morning at quarter to
five
quarter to five
because i had to pee and then i was like
okay well i gotta pee but then i'll go
back to sleep yeah that didn't happen so
i just laid there for
uh however long an hour and 15 minutes
until it was seven o'clock and then the
sun came up i was like well [ __ ] it i
guess i'm getting up so i got up and
made myself a cup of coffee and just
went to work so you know don't get a lot
of sleep is what i'm saying becca said
almond milk is is expensive yeah i think
it might be a little bit more expensive
than than dairy it is yeah
i will admit that
lasts a bit longer though the corp yeah
the carbohydrates the protein ratios a
little bit better and the car the the
calories are a fraction
so it's a lot more dietetic and it's
good in cereal yeah it's like 30
calories yeah per
cup or per half or whatever it is it's a
lot less calories
like as compared to whatever it is 80
hundred calories uh from now
because the way we've been programmed
since birth drinking that damn milk the
milk tastes a lot better it's it's
thicker and richer it's kind of like
unsweet but you know what
um
when i was younger i was really into
whole milk yeah
and
when i got into my 20s and i was like
man i need to lose some weight so i
stopped
so i stopped like drinking the whole
milk because i used to drink it
like glasses of it like every day
so i switched to skim
and i lost a lot of weight doing that
among other things
and
after that like after a couple of years
of drinking skim milk
when i went back to drink whole milk it
tasted like a milkshake
to me real thick and rich yeah it was
like real and so i couldn't like drink
it anymore because it
so it's all in what you get used to yeah
okay jen uh we're finished with the case
are we finished with that sure okay
all right um just seeing make sure that
that's wrapped up before we start going
down off on a damn tangent
um
jake says oh man i'd be in trouble if i
had to resort to seafood to live i'm not
a seafood guy at all some people aren't
um you know what's weird
my sister who is
seven years younger but in a lot of ways
even though she's seven years younger
we're like almost exactly the same in a
lot of ways
i joke with her that we share our brain
but the weird thing about her is that i
love seafood all kinds of seafood and
she hates seafood i think that's the
only thing that we're different about
other than that we're exactly the same
other than her being younger
but
i don't know man
my whole entire life
i have been so into
pretty much anything that comes out of
the ocean man i'll eat anything that
comes out of the ocean
within reason within reason
and she just will not
she likes tuna out of a can
or out of a pouch
but other than that she's like yeah no
thank you she's grossed out by it
but [ __ ] man i'll eat squid octopus
[ __ ] see an enemy
anything
anything comes out of the ocean i'll eat
that [ __ ]
she won't
weird
that's the only thing we're different
about
the only thing
but i understand some people are not
seafood people oh okay i will say i'm
not into like the whole
i'm not into the whole like caviar thing
not into fish eggs
none of that that's a little that's a
step too far
like i get okay if you want to like pay
hundred dollars to eat that that's fine
but i'm not gonna do that
other than that i'll eat shrimp i'll eat
fish i'll eat octopus i'll eat squid
see an enemy i'll eat any of that [ __ ]
eggs no thank you
no thank you but other than that
yeah i'm good
all right well it's 10 17. let's go
ahead and [ __ ] uh call it a night too
jake says my twin is the opposite of me
he'll eat all the seafood and i'm just
not having it
i'm a friend of the city i just won't
eat any of it i don't understand it man
there's a lot of good [ __ ] comes out
there is but like i said
if you don't want to eat stuff like i
get it it's a it's a distinctive flavor
and like i said my sister is the same
back in the 70s back over [ __ ] uh
back in the golden age when arnold and
all those guys were down there [ __ ]
venice beach
they were eating beef and all this [ __ ]
and getting pretty big and had his black
dude i'm trying to remember what his
name was
he he said about to prove that that you
could do it on fish and he went totally
[ __ ]
pescetarian and that he built a [ __ ]
fantastic physique on and you see when
you got these guys on these steroids
you're [ __ ] pushing it to the maximum
levels and when they're because they're
at the maximum levels you can really
judge how diet works and he was able to
build a fantastic physique he was
winning all kinds of [ __ ] back in those
days
so there's plenty of plenty of good
nutrition coming out of the sea and he
was
he was so lean looking he didn't have
any problem gaining any fat he just
gained muscle it's because of what he
was eating
fish is [ __ ]
real lean real good source of protein
he's eating fish and shellfish and just
yes
like i said i understand if some people
don't like it i get that yeah it does
have a distinctive flavor
and if you're not into it
you're not into it the only downside is
for the most part is the price
and it is very expensive it's expensive
depending on what part of the country
you're in because in new england
[ __ ] like lobster and chili is very very
cheap
but yeah it's still lobs are still
expensive in new england area though
it's just not as expensive as this here
not as it's it's still expensive yeah
i mean you know the cheapest seafood
i've been able to find around here is
that we go to the chinese buffet and sit
there and get the all you can eat buffet
and just raid the [ __ ] boiled shrimp
i'll sit there and eat [ __ ] three
pounds of shrimp
i'll punish them for putting those
shrimp out yeah the boiled shrimp and
the and the little uh the plant and the
the little clam or the mussels or
whatever i'll eat a bunch of those too
yeah
you pay a little bit extra then they'll
put out crab legs and [ __ ] punish
them crab legs that's dinner time that's
only dinner time yeah
yeah you can get a real clean meal at
[ __ ] all you can eat
chinese buffet if you know pick the
right one and you get the right stuff
don't eat any of the [ __ ] rice
just the meat and vegetables
like the [ __ ]
beef with [ __ ] peppers or the the
sauteed mushrooms put those on there
don't get any of that rice that's all
carbs or noodles or any of those even
though i love noodles yeah yeah they
they've invited you in
for an all-you-can-eat buffet you have
to punish them for that okay you go just
for the [ __ ] protest all the
presidents
[Music]
didn't know the carbs because that'll
like fill you up yeah just fill you up
and get your fat on that
yeah like save money you like your [ __ ]
all you can eat okay i'm gonna eat the
best [ __ ] you got
they hate thomas they hate me when i go
there but you ate all the shrimps yeah
but all [ __ ] i'll [ __ ] you know i
will [ __ ] up and go i gotta get a crab
rangoon with the [ __ ]
creams i get like one of those yeah i
get one couple of those at the end and
then like maybe a couple of pie stickers
you know what i mean but yeah i'll get
like one at the end if i still have room
because i'm making me hungry we need to
go [ __ ] koi
well maybe here tomorrow
or saturday or something tomorrow's uh
thursday oh i gotta go do a supply run
tomorrow too because we don't work
tomorrow
yeah i'm not gonna go down and [ __ ]
what you call it oh [ __ ] you gotta go to
samsung gotta go to sam's we're running
out of time i was gonna say we are
running out of food yeah i mean we're
not running out of food but
it's supplies
yeah
let's wrap this up jim we've been
[ __ ] streaming for too long it's
almost 10 o'clock at night we're usually
done with an hour from now we had all
these interruptions that's the only
reason why it went on i know like i'm
just glad that like i'm not mad
i mean i'm mad but you know what i mean
all right so hopefully we covered this
[ __ ] [ __ ] as well as could possibly
be expected because come on and thank
you for the super chat we did get we
only think we got one
but it's good we had to do the show
so you know whatever
all right so
we'll be back friday night now friday
night
we got to go out friday night yeah
because it's
yeah barbarella okay so we're at the
they're moving we'll have to end it soon
then so
okay they're doing like a memento mori
type of thing
on friday night but you know yeah our
club is moving that's been there for 37
years yeah the end of the club i'm
feeling a kind of way i'm feeling a kind
of way about it but i'm trying not to
get upset it's the end of an era
it is yeah but we'll see hopefully they
move to a better location but we're
gonna go out friday night but we will be
here friday night talking about whatever
we'll be dressed up
hopefully not drinking too much because
then we gotta like [ __ ] drive
downtown which is far but you know uh
thanks everybody for dropping by this
evening thanks for super chats and all
that other business hopefully like i
said i covered this [ __ ] as adequately
as could be expected considering the
circumstances
but uh you know all right so we'll be
back friday evening hope to see you guys
then
bye